salève bonjour alors vous êtes à lille
avec des gilet jaune ce que le cortège
est sur le point de démarrer
oui beaucoup de gilet jaune sont en
train de se rassembler ici place de la
république ils sont déjà très nombreux
plusieurs centaines ont répondu à
l'appel sur les réseaux sociaux
allez gilet jaune au sujet desquels
emmanuel macron a été interpellé ce
matin au salon de l'agriculture le chef
de l'état qui s'est dit ouvert au
dialogue et prête à recevoir certains
d'entre eux je me trouve avec un de
leurs représentants faouzi lellouche
bonjour monsieur que répondez vous
emmanuel macron bac il est temps il est
temps de vouloir dialoguer parce que ça
fait quand même
quatorze mois plus de 14 mois qu'on est
dans la rue sans réponse en faisant fi
comme si on n'était pas là donc et
malgré aussi un courrier qu'on a pu lui
faire courant novembre pour lui
présenter le vrai débat et pour aussi
essayé de parler des violences d'état
qui avait et tous les blessés et la
suite judiciaire qu'il pouvait y avoir
concernant les affaires dit gpn non
réglés et beaucoup d'interpellation de
notre part avec beaucoup de je crois
14000 personnes qui se sont retrouvées
au niveau de la justice à y répondre
donc je pense qu'il était temps qu il
écoute un petit peu les citoyens qui
sont mécontents dans ce pays avant même
que cette manifestation démarre il ya eu
quelques échanges tendus tout à l'heure
avec les crs est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire pourquoi
tout simplement parce qu'il ya
énormément de personnes qui ont été
bloqués à la gare de lille justement qui
voulaient se rendre à la manifestation
une rejoint dit si elle laissait pas
très loin ça a même pas 800 mètres et
ils sont bloqués là-bas donc vous avez
des parisiens mais vous avez aussi des
provinciaux qui ont décidé de venir pour
répondre à l'appel de l'île et
malheureusement on les bloque là bas
donc les gens ils ont voulu aller les
libérer quelque part pour les intégrer
dans le cortège et sur cette place et
puis du coup on en a été empêchée donc
ça a créé quelques tensions
voilà tout simplement il n'est pas il
est pas normal qu'aujourd'hui on puisse
pas se rendre à une manifestation
sereinement alors qu'elle a été déclaré
je sais qu'ici ils ont eu énormément de
problèmes pour pouvoir obtenir cette
autorisation
merci monsieur lellouche
voilà malgré quelques tensions dès le
début la manifestation va partir d'ici
quelques minutes à 14 heures 30 pour un
parcours de 3 km je rappelle que c'est
une manifestation déclarée est autorisée
par la préfecture la merci beaucoup
salle anne gaudin pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de lille